he says that quote so God himself is
inexpressible to all beings he alone has
none equal to him or like him none of
like Glory we call him unbegotten on
account of the one who by nature is
begotten we sing his Praises as without
beginning because of the one who has a
beginning we worship him as Eternal
because of him who was born in the order
of time the one without beginning
established the son as the beginning of
all creatures and having fathered such a
one he bore him as a son for himself he
the son possesses nothing proper to God
in the real sense of propriety for he is
not equal to God nor yet is he of the
same substance humos